torinese benvenuti in un nuovissimo
video era da tantissimo tempo che non
facevo un video on
e quindi ci stava farò un bel video
autunno inverno
partirei da un acquisto che ho fatto un
po di tempo fa ma che non vi ho ancora
spoilerato neanche su instagram ed è
bella bella bella bella mela metterò
live perché ovviamente è abbinata una
fantastica cintura di balenciaga
certo ovviamente ai di gucci ed è la mia
vita
la amo tantissimo cioè parte che con
questo vestito proprio alla morte sua
adesso che la fin ha posto posso
proseguire con gli altri acquisti questo
era diciamo il primo a farvelo vedere
per forza partiamo con gli acquisti che
ho fatto online non possono iniziare da
lei in che avete visto nel video che
metto qua sopra della mia beauty routine
e mi avete intasato di commenti per
sapere dove l'avessi comprata asus
semplicemente su asos costava anche
molto poco e quindi potete trovarla
l'idea misguided invece ho preso questa
gonna qui in molto molto sobria ne ho
comprata una l'anno scorso identica ma
rossa la gonna di pvc è un evergreen per
la stagione autunnale
poi passiamo alle paillettes
vestito classico chiuso di baguette la
gonna non è trasparente questa zona qua
invece trasparente quindi voi ovviamente
vi chiederete ma chi si vedono poi le
tette no cosa ti metti sotto dedico
fermate perché insieme al vestito c'è
ovviamente labbra let pajetta da
coordinata cioè questo è veramente un
tocco di classe che non poteva mancare
nel mio armadio delle meraviglie poi ho
acquistato questa gonna che io trovo
fantastica così probabilmente non vi
dirà nulla ma immaginate una vestibilità
a sirena quindi come se fosse una coda
di sirena molto molto aderente su
fianchi e lato b
e poi questo spacco davanti a una specie
di mini gonna sotto che arriva più o
meno metà corsa con tutto il resto è
nudo bell aver ovviamente ve lo farò
vedere indossata così non rende
abbastanza ma è molto molto particolare
e a proposito di sobrietà vedo del
pitone
questo è un completo che probabilmente
fa un po troppo freddino del sopra
mettono però magari in discoteca non
vado mai pantalone a zampa e top
guardate così praticamente con la
bretella storta finito lo shopping
online passiamo allo shopping classico
ho avuto la brillante idea di andare una
domenica al centro commerciale è
un'esperienza mistica che non facevo da
un po di anni
no ecco il punto è che c'erano così
tanti negozi così tanta gente che in
cinque ora ho visto tra i negozi cosa
che mi è dispiaciuta perché avrei dovuto
fare un punto più approfondito però
stava chiudendo quindi non potevo vedere
altri ne consuma torneo tornerò ci
rivedremo
allora partiamo da primark e
ho già intuito percepito dell'area
natalizia
[Musica]
vabbè io così questi fantastici
stivaletti ovviamente non sono per
uscire ma sono per ciabattare in casa
non mi guardare così riguardo perché io
sono molto freddo rosa mi prenderei
anche tu ok tra l'altro possono
veramente molto poco
sono molto pericolosa e quindi insieme
al calzettone di spugna antisesso cc
stanno ovviamente non coordinati perché
tipo il capitone sarà rosa tipo così e
questo aveva natalizio ci piace questo
mix è il look adatto per conquistare un
uomo vero consigli un fantastico
cappellino chi ci sta sempre color
fucsia come piace a me
ovviamente il pon pon è finto e bensì
acrilico allora chi di voi chi di voi mi
conosce veramente bene sa che io ho un
film cult nella mia adolescenza ed è
quindi quando immaginate la faccia che
ho fatto quando ho visto questa
è una cosa più bella del mondo allora
chi non l'avesse visto l'ingresso il
brand book era il diario dove la cattiva
della scuola la cattiva della
scuola scriveva tutte le cose cattive di
tutti gli studenti quindi i segreti
magari le cose che sentiva nei corridoi
eccetera eccetera appuntava e quindi era
praticamente gross un libro dello
sputtanamento della formula ecco e io
non potevo non averla cioè proprio
iconica questa felpa invece un pigiama
che trovato coordinato ma ho preso la l
di sopra è la m di sotto
ragazzi non c'erano le taglie cioè non
so cosa succede da primal però non li ho
ancora provati me li farò stare allora
non poteva non prendere il pigiama di
barbie anche questo abbastanza iconico e
la parte sopra va beh può stare un po
larga così i pantaloni e quest'anno
molto molto molto minuti ne ho paura di
navigarci però ci sono i cordini quindi
farò una roba tipo alla fantozzi e siamo
a posto
secondo voi potevo non avere una cuffia
da bagno con malefica crudelia demon
ursula disegnate sopra non potevano la
perla doveva essere mia
magari mi sarà gigante anche se proviamo
la live
forse mr io uscirò così le mani
passiamo da h m devo preso un altro
fantastico berretto poi non so se lo
sapete ma io potrei fare un video hi
tech del berretto ne ho tanti tutti i
colori l'arcobaleno io già attrezzata
per i giorni più freddi
non potevo passare inosservata anche
l'inverno 15 st il piumino tigrato cosa
tigre bengala lo so che voi volete
vederle indossati però sarebbe un video
veramente troppo lungo
ogni volta mi dite maria perché non li
indossi ma tanto chi è bravo e mi segue
su instagram vede ovviamente una volta
comprati una volta tirati fuori dalle
buste inizia indossarle quindi vede live
quindi dovete seguirmi su libero però
vivo è persone e questa sarà la
quindicesima maglia a collo alto nera
del mio armadio
io in inverno metto solo il collo alto
nero cioè se non esistesse con alto nero
probabilmente non uscire di casa perché
mi sento proprio nuda nel senso che ho
la gola molto delicata adesso si passa
dalla moda a la visita medica o la donna
molto sensibile
appena prende un colpo d'aria morta cioè
a letto influenzata quindi ho questa
abitudine di indossare solo con loro
ovviamente fuori poi dentro maracaibo
se avete visto riverdance non potrete
non riconoscere in questo ambito che vi
sto per far vedere uno dei personaggi
volevi il fuoco
beh la mia specialità il ghiaccio share
il bonus share
chi sono veronica no dai è proprio
veronica se mi metto la parrucca col
caschetto non al caffè con le spalle e
uno stivale nero alto con il tacco un
giro di perle sono lei sberluccicanti
sempre lui ma serale nel senso uno ci
può andare tranquillamente a fare una
cena con amici e dopo andare a ballare
magari sotto si mette una pera lechner a
questo sopra un bel pantalone nero a
zampa finiamo il tour di h m con un
colore molto sobrio questo completo di
velluto a coste
il suo crop top con questa scollatura
fessura quindi abbiamo sì una scollatura
a cuore in questo video della scollatura
a fessura da h m zara è un attimo
ormai è diventato iconico ha fatto il
giro di tik tok perché l'ho utilizzato
per fare questa challenge come avere
scuole che dai i cori two is being ma
ormai è un fantastico cappello da
pioggia che tra l'altro sta usando
veramente questi giorni in cui avevano
stati diluviando e che è molto comodo
questi non li apprezzo tanto cioè a meno
che ci sia una tormenta e quindi
potrebbe andare più o meno così e quindi
ti serve che ti sia legato al collo
per il resto lo trovo un po anti
estetico quindi probabilmente farò un
tagli e cuci guardate che carina che
carina questa gonna
no è una gonna pantalone in realtà rossa
con questo particolare anche questo devo
dire che potrebbe essere abbastanza
veronica loggia tubino nero con queste
mani che super cioè anni ottanta ips
allora c'è zara regali veramente delle
grandi emozioni e poi per finire ho
preso questo completo pantalone
normalissimo sempre a sigaretta
quanta colla diciamo però con la zip e
il bottone qui sul lato c'è un sono
cuciti degli strass scuri però non sono
argentati sono sul nero e sopra
pronta per le vacanze di natale e
maglioncino che richiama ovviamente col
nero con questo fiocco qui e anche
questo ha nel paillettes quindi un look
non scontato ma non per questo esagerato
forse ho finito ho finito fatemi sapere
che cosa vi ha vinto di più ovviamente
visto che so che mi piacciono tanto
questi video ne farò altri prima di
natale compro l'altro roba però questo
diciamo che sono le cosine che ho
iniziato a prendere per i primi freddi
commentate qui sotto facendomi sapere
cosa vi è piaciuto di più
mi raccomando se non avete ancora fatto
iscrivetevi al canale e cliccate sulla
campanella per ricevere una notifica
tutte le volte che fu di chrome video e
soprattutto per vedere questi outfit
indossati una volta per tutte seguitemi
anche su instagram perché quella è la
mia passerella dove in dosso tutte le
cose che compro vi mando un bacione
enorme e ci vediamo al prossimo video
[Musica]